what's it like skating with Justin
Bieber
he rips he does rip and I really respect
this about him
the fact that he actually genuinely
loves skateboarding like when I when I
skated with him I had met him a few
times before that but that was the first
time we really kicked it at my skate
park back a couple years ago that was
when he did the inward heel flip yeah
yeah and he was like
he oh he was barely even like talking to
anyone like some of our friends were
there hanging out he was like on it the
whole time just like skating and just
hyped up what year was that really likes
it
um that was I think like 2020. the one
thing I noticed about Justin Bieber was
when we did that clown thing in Venice
yeah he that was with 2014.
so maybe he was six years worse than he
was now so he was just starting and we
were at the Venice the skate parking on
the beach right there and he came out
and he had everybody was watching him
and he wasn't good I mean he was he was
doing [ __ ] and he was eating [ __ ] and
everybody was like you know [ __ ] like
everybody was talking [ __ ] from the
crowd like looking at him and he just
didn't give a [ __ ] that wasn't my take
on it really that wasn't my take on it
but yeah but that was the one thing I
noticed like he did not give a [ __ ]
anybody and he just kept doing his stuff
and then pick up the board and do it
again and it was like yeah I couldn't do
that I mean it was incredible he just
shut everybody out yeah what was your
take on it
he was comfortable with just skating and
having everybody filming on their cell
phones and he's not necessarily making
the tricks that he's going for and and
he was okay with that and then and that
isn't aggressive that's the same thing I
said is better worded I don't remember
anybody screaming [ __ ] or anything like
that the way you described it really I
mean nobody was hating on them they were
just paying attention to him because
everybody was hating on them because he
was Justin Bieber and he's a rich
[ __ ] 20 year old and all these people
you know what I mean it's like I I don't
remember anybody vocalizing anything
negative towards him yeah I just
remember him getting a lot of attention
well either way it's probably just so
used to that you know it was because it
was incredible daily life it was next
level yeah have you skated with Lil
Wayne I'm scared with him a couple times
too yeah he's got his own skate park he
loves skateboarding
there yeah I still need to go there yeah
like that in Florida right is it yeah in
Miami yeah he really [ __ ] loves it
too though it's crazy really [ __ ]
loves it like didn't he put out a music
video and a Tim skating
I mean I almost feel like part of the
reason why you stopped putting out so
much music was because you started
skating and he was just so hyped on that
that's cool yeah it's great and then and
he you know like he I think it Lil
Wayne's approached skating is like
super healthy and that he doesn't care
how his skating Stacks up against like
all the footage out there he's just
competing for with himself to get better
than he was before yeah yeah that's like
I I'm so jealous of bam like when when
jackass started like you know I had kind
of given up on on my skating I was just
like man I'm not I'm not good enough at
skating I'm just gonna like do all this
crazy stunt [ __ ] and be in skateboard
videos not skating and then you know we
get the jackass thing going and Bam did
both you know and I look back on those
ears and think why did I uh
compare myself to everybody else I could
have just stuck with it and just worried
about outskating myself yeah if I just
try to outskate myself then I'm a happy
guy I know I feel like I hear that a lot
I feel like a lot of people get
discouraged easily and they're like oh
I'm not not good enough at this so I
don't want to do it when I always tell
people like you really don't have to be
an insanely good skateboarder to have
fun with it like if you can if you can
ollie and like maybe do a kickflip and
like if you can grind if you can grind
some Ledges grind some little rails you
will have a lot of [ __ ] fun yeah yeah
it's no secret that Johnny Knoxville and
I are a little older too old to deliver
the mail but we can still lick the stamp
and I think we look pretty good right
here this Remains the
means the ever signed for selling yeah
this
is filming
everybody grab these Johnny O
skateboards while you can I'd suggest
you hurry